can't talk I know try show so she'll bid
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans you're watching
hot ones the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings today I'm joined by
Eddie Wong you might know him from
Bauhaus Long's world he's got a new book
double cup love out May 31st I read it
over the weekend and given what you said
about the way the hot pot kind of hits
your stomach I'm a little worried about
you with this show ya know I have a
tendency to have explosive diarrhea it's
got me there's a lot of us with ideas
Massa real fraternity secret handshake
the CIB a secret handshake is just the
elbow I'm and you ready to give this
started
all right so first one sriracha your
food
wait a second though I think you just
made an almost like horrible mistake I'm
going hot first you are yeah I'm going
dumb deep diving in the deep end I'm
just gonna get it done it's to work
ready I'm gonna go the other way so
we're going opposite ways this will be
weird oh yeah this is no joke it's a
little nippy I mean to go make a dent
sauce right off the bat open up crazy
move I don't who tried got to the white
meat of you won't look good you just did
a crazy thing I think you're gonna rule
what part here care a lot about food
obviously and you've written a lot about
love lately I wonder do you have any
first date turn-ons something that would
turn you on the boots I'm in boots
you're in I'm way into like thigh high
boots
yeah what about the way she orders food
off the menu is there anything that will
turn you on oh oh god damn I'm gonna
keep going cuz it's on
alright number two oh so hot you're
insane this is a crazy move how does the
hooters and Chen do compared to say a
Hooters in Daytona Beach Florida
there's no Hooters in Chengdu there's
not no I mean the girls didn't really
have a hooters [ __ ] Eddie going in
reverse order
whoo so there's a Hooters franchise
there right yeah my brother got food
poisoning
eating the Caesar salad down who really
yeah how did the oddest places compare
this is pain oh [ __ ] this is no joke oh
you went jumping into the deep end
cannonball style I was worried about
pooping [ __ ] I'm worried about my life
do you want my know how much liquid ever
I drink
oh you gotta tap the sound room no I'm
out don't do this this was [ __ ] oh my
god how spicy pick up Rafi oh my god can
you die from this
you got more napkins good god I don't
know what you did to me dude
don't put this one on me this one's on
you starting at ten how much liquid did
I drink so I haven't had any it took out
at least two glasses of water plus that
much in the picture and a glass of milk
can I go to the bathroom again yeah yeah
do people finish them yeah like all ten
Wow
dude that was so painful let's get us a
cake full I puked in the sink
I took a giant hot [ __ ] and then I
accidentally touched my dick so now my
dicks on fire for the rest of this
interview don't feel bad it's something
that's happened to me a thousand times I
always finish the show I go take a piss
cuz I drink a bunch of water and then I
end up lighting my dick on fire every
single episode I must have like done
something terrible recently like to
deserve this you say that about our [ __ ]
no no no you are one of our most
requested guess it would be nice if we
can talk to you a little bit let's elbow
oh cool there we go man you ready to
move on to number three okay tiene mucho
mucho um I'm sure I'm eating do you get
to number ten every time mm-hmm
oh wow no one's ever flamed out that
fast
and I want to scream ever not even
Khalid but no I don't think I mean
anymore wings man
I gotta warm up I can't wait to wash my
dick and milk when I get home xanthan
Eber Dan basically said that every food
show sucks except for his yours and
actions do you think that you and
Bourdain are cut from the same kind of
cloth or what do you think I think we
both genuinely understand that there's a
narrative the food besides just what's
on the plate and then this is like a
starting point for the conversation I
don't think he I think the thing that
yeah I'm sorry it's hard to think with
my [ __ ] dick on fire but like I think
the thing that we both do is we are
trying to seek the truth like our own
version of the truth or whatever and try
to represent it as straightforward and
objectively as we can what do you do for
this do you just take a glass of milk
and [ __ ] pour it on yourself I don't
know I think I was your enough man you
know you know how during the NFL try to
go to bed okay cool
oh this is dicks on fire number four now
what do we what am I at Payne is good
Louisiana style you've gone from the
internet to Network twice I wonder what
are some of the dumb suggestions
comments the feedback that network execs
give you I'm gonna stand oh go ahead
Eddie wolf man what are some of the dumb
questions you know I always find it
funny when people are like so how did
you come to love hip hop and I'm just
like kind of like why do you like
buffalo wings like before today I mean
it's pretty self-explanatory why
somebody would like buffalo wings do you
know I mean and it's always like because
I'm Chinese there has to be this like
huge origin story about why I like hip
hop you know like you don't go ask a
basketball player like there why do you
like basketball you kind of your as a
kid you see something you like you
gravitate towards it then it becomes
part of your life you know I constantly
have to explain that or give some origin
story and then they'll look at me like
as if my story is good enough for them
and I'm just like well if I listen to
what like Taylor Swift and I wouldn't be
asked these questions our games
completely out of whack at this point
but always got to point out this is
actually our hot sauce I'm not gonna
have you try it but hot ones hot sauce
should always call out the plug I always
call us plus you know at first we feast
we've criticized the way that food is
covered now for quite some time and you
certainly never hold your tongue when it
comes to that situation yeah what do you
think is the biggest problem in food
media in 2016 I feel like if you have to
explain why something's good it's
probably not very good I want to eat
food and she's like this tasted good if
someone has to tell me I did this and I
did that and I created this foam and
then I burned this and put it on top and
that's why you should like it and I
probably shouldn't like it
putting chefs on a pedestal and treating
them like food gods it's kind of
hilarious because at the end of the day
like most of our mothers can run circles
around these clowns opening restaurants
you know I mean
everyone gets three meals a day to
practice breakfast lunch and dinner so I
feel like it doesn't take an expert to
explain food to me I'd rather watch some
idiot like myself just burn his face off
and set his dick on fire eating hot
wings you know you're somebody who puts
out work and a bunch of different types
of mediums I wonder which criticism are
you more sensitive to or which criticism
do you find more insufferable is it the
food critic versus the TV critic versus
the book critic the TV ones are funny
because I feel like TV critics at least
like with the ABC show fresh off the
boat I was demanding more than the
critics were and it's very interesting I
feel at least in network television
people accept like a certain standard so
that was an interesting realization for
me the worst review I've ever gotten was
from Sam system but I think it was the
most important review of my life it was
a zero star review for a restaurant
because I was like [ __ ] around I was
throwing all you can drink four loko
parties I mean it was an insane
restaurant we open for three months I
remember one of my homegirls was so
wasted in the restaurant she couldn't
tell that the door was a sliding door
and she drank so much for local she ran
into the door shoulder rammed it and the
door fell off in the middle of service
so it was like you know what we deserved
a zero star review I needed a wake-up
call and he was like you're a talented
kid but you're [ __ ] around you're
probably a little too successful at an
early age and not taking this seriously
and that review not only changed the way
I approached food but everything in my
life I'm gonna top 5 Dead or Alive from
you but I want you to pick the category
so I got clean for you either chefs
rappers or maybe lawyers because we
aren't you a lawyer before you start
selling weed right yeah yeah let's just
go wrappers man I'm more interested in
rappers and chefs let's do top 5 dead or
alive anyone rappers 5 dead or alive all
right you know when I do top 5 I never
go with like who I think is actually the
best what do you thinks that he thought
is big for me overall everything number
one and then after him I don't really
pay attention to say who I think is the
tech
we best my favorite rapper all-time is
Cameron I always said his cam he did
your song yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
theme song yeah did the theme song
delicious Shanghai Moscow check out the
kitchen alley
discovery fishes I've always known the
Dipset dudes and I've always been number
one cam fan so cams number one um
number two is probably Jeezy like I just
listened to a lot of Jeezy when I like
cook when I work three
I gotta go Kanye I run yang like Kanye a
lot then I gotta go
I love future I'm a big future head I
like future and then and then five i'ma
put out Castle cuz I feel like sometimes
cats are too nostalgic and they just put
the old names in everyone's always like
biggie pop yeah jay-z like everybody has
the same be exact this is my five that
I'm banging still respect it all the
time alright this is the bomb this is a
worse Oh Oh Moses oh that's how you make
it to ten you drop on the floor so I
feel like you know uh New York New
Yorkers for the longest for so anti LA
right yeah so anti LA but I feel like
that's softened quite a bit you yourself
I'm left over there's yeah what's the
most Hollywood thing you've done since
you've been out there I mean like you
you catch me at the Chateau sometimes a
real Chateau oh I go hiking why do the
hiking dates you I did cryotherapy my
boy Iran took me to cryotherapy where
you go in and it's like zero degrees and
it reduces the inflammation in your body
ivy him like vegan food and stuff so I
got onto the LA health wave your way I'm
into it I'm into it just like this you
know I move straight to Malibu I got the
drive that's just you I started hiking
yet I'm like if you're gonna go do it
embrace it I look at you now but you
know fam this is something new some
water healthy also morning this is such
an interesting episode
Mad Dog 357 two-spirit hottest sauce
it's our second hottest sauce but you
already know that yeah you know - Mad
Dog is what set me off though it was hot
lairs is kind of tasty
yeah the Blair's was tasty the Mad Dog
was just like bad that was like the 350
hit combo on Street Fighter which
Orlando tourist attraction do local
Orlando people have the most respect for
I mean you're on the Harry Potter head
so I [ __ ] with Harry Potter
I love the Harry Potter situation at
Universal which store helped riders up
there with camera which tourist
attraction do like people who live in
Orlando respect the least dude I feel
like our town is just it's shameless
like there's nothing that's like off
limits you know I mean I remember
working like pirate's dinner adventure
where I had to dress up like a pirate
and [ __ ] take photos of people in
high school that was terrible so really
humbled me and I feel like even though
I'm doing alright I just remember these
days at pirate's dinner theater you know
oh oh see throughout half a wingman
Eddie
oh you're gonna put more sauce on it so
it's kind of a tradition around here we
just dab the last one
I'm getting nervous watching like my leg
is twitching cuz I'm like what if I
touch the other side of my dick
typically we take the bite together but
you cruise through this one so I'll just
do this solo dolo and I'll ask you the
question if you were mayor of New York
what would be your first order of
business what would be the dick
day 1 action ok this is a good one I
really think that the answer is to
constantly maintain healthy and equal
opportunity for competition in this
country the Republicans are constantly
trying to remove competition and create
monopolies create industries that are
too big to fail hoping that then the
money trickles down it doesn't work but
then on the other side you have to help
the smaller businesses absorb this and
also help the small midsize businesses
to retain talent businesses that you
could open or I could open they're not
available as options we allow these
things to get so big and monopolized
that for dudes like us on the ground I
mean what can you create we have to
maintain competition and we have to help
build more opportunities for people to
be small business owners Teddy I kind of
made it through you I think technically
did yeah you take out the chair and let
deserves respect Eddie this will be an
episode summer hot packed on those four
do you have before I get out do you have
any advice for other people that are on
the show number one advice start from
this side
number two advice don't touch a dick
good strong advice it's a fun show you
just can't dumb out like I did
plug away let the people know what you
got going on oh yeah no we got Wong's
world on the air right now Thursdays
10:00 p.m. of Iceland and then the book
double couple of May 31st because I made
it through I'm taking some plug too if
you're an athlete if you're an actor if
you're a musician if you're some teacher
who never thought I'd amount to much
growing up coach Donner
mr. Guthrie I didn't forget come on into
the hot one stage take on some wings
take on some questions Eddie
they go coming through nice to meet you
- have fun